[Music]
hey i think this guy's a couple can
short of a six-pack you're close
give them to me now
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
welcome to the 1980s the decade with
some of the best and most iconic movies
ever
we came we saw we kicked it did you see
it what is it we got it now for this
list we focused on works that
represented the cinematic trends and
social themes of the era from epic
fantasies to coming-of-age tales i mean
this list has it all this is a big one
the one i've been waiting for all my
life uh well it's a delorean stay with
me marty all your questions will be
answered roll tape so
fire up the flux capacitor and cue the
workout montage because we are counting
down the best movies of the 1980s
[Music]
number 10 die hard
new york city policeman john mclean is
visiting his estranged wife and kids on
christmas eve hence making die hard a
christmas movie sorry that's just how i
feel he joins her at a holiday party in
the headquarters of the japanese owned
business that she works for but the
festivities are interrupted by a group
of terrorists who take over the
exclusive high-rise and everyone in it
soon mclean realizes that there's no one
to save the hostages but him starring
bruce willis alan rickman bonnie bedelia
and directed by john mctiernan critics
say die hard's many imitators and
sequels have never come close to
matching the top thrills of the
definitive holiday action classic
[Music]
there's something wrong they're coming
back down
blow the roof the car's up there
i promise i will never even think about
going up in a tall
please don't let me die
[Music]
number nine raging bull
the story of a middleweight boxer as he
rises through ranks to earn his first
shot at the middleweight crown he falls
in love with a gorgeous girl from the
bronx and the inability to express his
feelings enters into the ring and
eventually takes over his life he
eventually is sent into a downward
spiral that costs him everything
starring robert de niro cathy moriarty
joe pesci and directed by martin
scorsese critics say arguably martin
scorsese and robert de niro's finest
film raging bull is often painful to
watch but it's a searing powerful work
about an unsympathetic hero
in detroit for their second fight the
undefeated sugar ray defeated jacob
madison
you can see the contrast in their styles
the speedy ray robinson up on his toes
the dancing master
lamontagne for the most of the time
[Applause]
robinson comes back with a right on the
nose
drives him across the ring a left and a
right to the head a hard left head to
the body and robinson has driven out of
the ring for the first knockdown of his
career
this is the nearest
[Music]
the undefeated sugar ray his winning
ways are in jeopardy
[Applause]
number eight star wars episode 5 the
empire strikes back
luke skywalker han solo princess leia
and chewbacca face attack by the
imperial forces and it's at at walkers
at the ice planet hoth while han and
leia escape in the millennium falcon
luke travels to dagobah in search of
yoda only with the jedi master's help
will luke survive when the dark side of
the force beckons him into the ultimate
duel with darth vader starring mark
hamill harrison ford carrie fisher and
directed by ervin kirschner critics say
dark sinister but ultimately even more
involving than a new hope the empire
strikes back defies viewer expectations
and takes the series to heightened
emotional levels
[Music]
[Music]
your destiny lies with me skywalker i'll
be one news to be true
perhaps you are not as strong as the
emperor of thought
[Music]
impressive
favorite
most impressive
[Music]
[Music]
release your anger
only your hatred can destroy me
number seven raiders of the lost ark
dr indiana jones a renowned
archaeologist and expert in the occult
is hired by the us government to find
the ark of the covenant which is
believed to still hold the ten
commandments unfortunately hitler's
agents are also after the ark indy and
his ex flame marion escape from various
close scrapes in a quest that takes him
from nepal to cairo starring harrison
ford karen allen paul freeman and
directed by steven spielberg critics say
featuring brevura set pieces sly humor
and white knuckle action raiders of the
lost ark is one of the most consummately
entertaining adventure pictures of all
time
[Music]
huh
[Music]
no time to argue throw me the idol i
throw you the whip
give me
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
number six back to the future
in the 1980s sci-fi classic small-town
california teen marty mcfly is thrown
back into the 50s when an experiment by
his eccentric scientist friend doc brown
goes awry traveling through time in a
modified delorean car marty encounters
young versions of his parents and must
make sure that they fall in love or
he'll cease to exist even more
dauntingly marty has to return to his
own time and save the life of doc brown
starring michael j fox christopher lloyd
leah thompson and directed by robert
zemeckis critics say inventive funny and
breathlessly constructed back to the
future is a rousing time travel
adventure with an unforgettable spirit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
number five big after a wish turns 12
year old josh baskin into a 30 year old
man he heads to new york city and gets a
low level job at macmillan toy company a
chance encounter with the owner of the
company leads to a promotion testing new
toys soon a fellow employee susan
lawrence takes a romantic interest in
josh however the pressure of living as
an adult begins to overwhelm him and he
longs to return to his simple former
life as a boy starring tom hanks
elizabeth perkins robert loggia and
directed by penny marshall critics say
refreshingly sweet and undeniably funny
big is a showcase for tom hanks who
dives into his role and infuses it with
charm and surprising poignancy
i loved your ideas on the squeezy doll
line
thanks
so much
it's beluga
mcmillan orders it every year
all right
okay you want a glass of water
number four ghostbusters
after the members of a team of
scientists lose their cushy positions at
a university in new york city they
decide to become quote ghostbusters to
wage a high-tech battle with the
supernatural for money they stumble upon
a gateway to another dimension a doorway
that will release evil upon the city the
ghostbusters must now save new york from
complete destruction starring bill
murray dan aykroyd harold ramis and
directed by ivan reitman critics say
ghostbusters is an infectiously fun
blend of special effects in comedy with
bill murray's hilarious deadpan
performance leading a cast of great
comic turns
all right
this chick is toast
[Music]
[Music]
got your stick
let's show this prehistoric fish how we
do things downtown
[Music]
we're gonna go full stream aim for the
flat top
one so hard
number three say anything
in a charming critically acclaimed tale
first love lloyd an eternal optimist
seeks to capture the heart of diane an
unattainable high school beauty and
straight a student it surprises just
about everyone when she returns a
sentiment but diane's overly possessive
divorced father doesn't approve and it
will take more than the power of love to
conquer all starring john cusack ioni
sky john mahoney and directed by cameron
crowe critics say one of the definitive
generation x movies say anything is
equally funny and heartfelt and it
established john cusack as an icon for
left of center types everywhere
you mean like career
um
i don't know i
thought about this quite a bit sir and i
i would have to say considering what's
waiting out there for me
i don't want to sell anything buy
anything or process anything as a career
i don't want to sell anything bought or
processed or buy anything sold or
processed or
process anything so bought or processed
or repair anything sold bought or
processed you know as a career i don't
want to do that
so uh my father's in the army
he wants me to join but i can't work for
that corporation
um so what i've been doing lately is
kickboxing
number two e.t the extraterrestrial
after a gentle alien becomes stranded on
earth the being is discovered and
befriended by a young boy named elliot
bringing the extraterrestrial into his
suburban california house elliott
introduces e.t as the alien is dubbed to
his brother and his little sister gertie
and the children decide to keep its
existence a secret soon however e.t
falls ill resulting in government
intervention and a dire situation for
both elliot and the alien starring henry
thomas d wallace peter coyote and
directed by steven spielberg critics say
playing is both an exciting sci-fi
adventure and a remarkable portrait of
childhood steven spielberg's e.t the
extraterrestrial a touching tale of a
homesick alien remains a piece of movie
magic for young and old
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
tell me when it's over
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
do the right thing
sal is the italian owner of a pizzeria
in brooklyn a neighborhood local bugging
out becomes upset when he sees that the
pizzeria's wall of fame exhibits only
italian actors buggin owl believes a
pizzeria in a black neighborhood should
showcase black actors but sal disagrees
the wall becomes a symbol of racism and
hate to bugging out and to other people
in the neighborhood and tensions rise
starring dania yellow giancarlo esposito
richard edson and spike lee who also
directed the film critics say smart
vibrant and urgent without being
didactic do the right thing is one of
spike lee's most fully realized efforts
and one of the most important films of
the 1980s rarely do i see any american
italians eating here all i see is black
folks so since we spend much money here
we do have some set
you're looking for trouble
are you a troublemaker is that what you
are
you making trouble yeah i'm a
troublemaker i'm making trouble you're a
real ball breaker
nobody's coming in here looking for
trouble huh
suppose i busted your head how would you
i'm looking
look you want to get your friend out of
here why are you gonna kick me out now
are you gonna kick me out huh no i'm not
kicking you out you're kicking yourself
out what look what's the brother's up on
the wall you know malcolm x nelson
mandela you know what you're michael
jordan tomorrow come on get him out all
right i'm trying to get him out i paid
his life
i know you paid for let's go
raising arizona
an ex-con and x caught me marry and long
for a child of their own when it is
discovered that he's unable to have
children they decide to snatch a baby
they try to keep their crime a secret
while friends co-workers and a bounty
hunter look to use a child for their own
purposes starring nicholas cage holly
hunter trey wilson and directed by joel
cohen critics say a terrifically
original eccentric screwball comedy
raising arizona may not be the cohen's
most disciplined movie but it's one of
their most purely entertaining
hi
it's two in the morning
what's that smell
we don't always smell this way miss
mcdonough
i was just explaining to your better
half here that when we were tunneling
out we happened to hit the main sewer
line dumb luck that
and we followed that
busted out of jail no ma'am uh we
released crushes on our own recognizing
whatever here is trying to say is that
we felt the institution no longer had
anything to offer us
my lord he's cute he's a little outlaw
you can see that high now listen you
folks can't stay here
ma'am you just can't stay
now i appreciate you being friends of
high and all but this is a decent family
now
i mean we got a toddler here
say who wears the pants around here h.i
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention
the breakfast club five high school
students from different walks of life
endure saturday detention under a power
hungry principle the disparate group
includes rebel john princess claire
outcast allison brainy brian and andrew
the jock each has a chance to tell his
or her story making the other seem a
little different and when the day ends
they question whether school will ever
be the same starring emilio estevez
molly ringwald judd nelson and directed
by john hughes critics say the breakfast
club is a warm insightful and a very
funny look into the inner lives of
teenagers
what's that
sushi
sushi
rice uh raw fish and seaweed
you won't accept a guy's tongue in your
mouth and you're gonna eat that can i
eat
i don't know
give it a try
[Applause]
and finally number one the terminator
disguised as a human a cyborg assassin
known as a terminator travels from 2029
to 1984 to kill sarah connor sent to
protect sarah is kyle reese who divulges
the coming of skynet an artificial
intelligence system that will spark a
nuclear holocaust sarah is targeted
because skynet knows that her unborn son
will lead the fight against them with
the virtually unstoppable terminator in
hot pursuit she and kyle attempt to
escape starring arnold schwarzenegger
linda hamilton michael bean and directed
by james cameron critics say with its
impressive action sequences taught
economic direction and relentlessly fast
pace it's clear why the terminator
continues to be an influence on sci-fi
and action flicks
[Music]
[Music]
great places
[Music]
faster
drive faster
down
[Music]
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you